in order to recover from many kinds of
mental distress there's really no
alternative but to get acquainted with
psychotherapy
though often dense and complicated the
central ideas of psychotherapy can be
summarized as follows
every human is in part neurotic a
Neurosis is any pattern of thinking or
behavior that blocks the full flowering
of our personalities and potential we
may be neurotic in love or at work in
our friendships or in our attitudes to
creativity or politics it should be part
of every evolved human's mission to seek
to understand and unpick the neurotic
elements of their own personalities the
inquiry and how are you neurotic should
not be taken as an insult rather a
sensible and kindly request for more
information on our particular share of
Humanity's warps
the origins of most of our neuroses lie
in our childhoods before we were old
enough to deploy adult mechanisms to
process events what causes neuroses are
incomprehensible cruel and intolerable
frustrations and pains that we can
collectively refer to as traumas
a trauma may be as immediately shocking
as a rape or as seemingly innocuous as
years of continuous Petty criticism or
emotional neglect something qualifies as
a trauma because of an unmasterable
Dimension the child is not able to make
sense of the agony it faces and so
suffers a grievous blow to its sense of
self and command of trust intelligence
and love
every parental inadequacy tends to give
rise to a Neurosis where there is an
over-controlling parent there will be a
child with problems around autonomy
where there is a belittling parent there
will be a child with difficulties of
confidence and self-esteem where there
is a sexual rivalry or seductiveness
there will be issues of guilt or shame
every character defect on the side of
the parent necessarily imposes a toll on
a child
there is no such thing as an unneerotic
parent rather than deny that they could
have done anything wrong all parents
must simply put up their hands
gracefully perhaps humorously too and
then assist their child in figuring out
the particular difficulties they will
have bequeathed to them
trauma leads to repression which over
time inspires the formation of neurotic
symptoms neuroses that have not been
understood continue into perpetuity time
never weakens them
healing comes through self-awareness to
improve we need to Dynamite the concrete
of repression and recover contact with
the original trauma and in order to do
that we need to accept before anything
else that doing so would be a good idea
we have to agree that self-knowledge
will be what can save us
it won't be enough to know the past we
will need to feel it too we may have a
workable sense of the central details of
our childhoods but an intellectual grasp
won't be enough we need to viscerally
re-experience rather than merely
intellectually know the past so as to
free ourselves from its hold on a roses
will weaken and dissolve once the
traumas that fire them are finally known
and even more importantly felt
that is the challenge and the promise of
psychotherapy
the School of Life offers online
Psychotherapy to people all around the
world our therapists are highly trained
and accredited and are a vital source of
kindness Solace and wisdom for life's
most difficult moments click the link to
find out more